[Music]
it may be better
and wetter under the sea but what
sebastian forgot to mention
is that it's also full of plot holes
down there for disney movies plot holes
aren't a huge surprise
they're fairy tales after all but when
it comes to the little mermaid there are
just
too many unexplained storylines to not
notice
you might not have paid any attention to
these plot holes when you were younger
but after you watch this video you won't
be able to look at ariel
eric and their sea friends the same way
again don't worry the little mermaid
will always be our nostalgic childhood
go-to but we're poor unfortunate souls
no more
ah remember how perfect we all thought
the kiss the girl scene was
what's more romantic than a prince
whisking you away for a private boat
ride that ends in a first kiss
for kid us the answer is absolutely
nothing
but if you watch that scene today you
might find yourself feeling a little
frustrated
at this point ariel has no voice and
can't tell eric about her whole ursula
situation
but her friend sebastian is there and
even whispers ariel's name into eric's
ear
so why couldn't sebastian just fill in
eric on what was going on
it would have saved a whole lot of time
continuing on the track of why couldn't
ariel find another way to tell eric
about ursula
we have plot hole number two why didn't
ariel just write down sentences to
communicate with eric instead of just
using hand gestures
you might argue that maybe she didn't
learn how to read or write in mermaid
school but
she read and wrote when she signed
ursula's contract this is either a plot
hole the writers never considered
or they just really need to carry out
the situation until the final match up
at the end of the film
the plot holes don't just surround ariel
either there's some mystery around eric
in his beginnings
like where exactly are his parents we
see him spend his time with his butler
and companion grim
but we don't ever see anyone else in his
family his title is also still prince
which means there has to be a king and
queen
maybe it's an elsa situation where he
still hasn't had his coronation
mermaids are fish right so it's
interesting that ariel doesn't find
anything wrong with prince eric's diet
during their lunch at the palace she
does manage to save sebastian from
becoming a meal but doesn't have a
problem when grim and eric go to town on
their meals
that also include crabs it's loki kind
of morbid
[Music]
we all know how important disney music
is to disney films but does a music
sequence
automatically mean the outside world
can't hear them because that's exactly
what happened in the little mermaid
after ariel saves eric from drowning we
have the iconic moment where she sings
part of your world
while he's still passed out for most of
it she's belting out the loudest note
ever when he wakes up and gets help from
grim
so how did he not hear her it's
impossible
we know we know love at first sight is a
huge deal for disney stories
but all we're saying is that ariel and
eric seemed to be acting a tad
prematurely when it came to basically
giving up their lives for one another
ariel was ready to give up everything
she'd ever known to be with him
including her voice and while yes she
also wanted to be human apart from eric
she didn't need to get married to him
that quick it's all just a little
rushed the next one might be a little
silly but we still need answers
we all know disney princesses always
look picture perfect
but ariel must have had something
magical going on with her red locks
despite literally living in the water
her hair was
never wet never i mean not even the best
product could last underwater for that
long
we have to know her secret we may never
see eric's parents but we do see his
best friend
his dog max just like ariel does with
sebastian and flounder he uses him as
basically his guide and sometimes
voice of reason but there's one major
difference between ariel's pals
and max he can't speak why is that if
all the sea creatures can have
conversations with humans why doesn't
the same apply to creatures on land
so many double standards ariel
stop talking crazy we gotta see him
again
ursula is a huge part of the little
mermaid there would literally be no
story without her but funnily enough
we literally know nothing about her
what's her backstory
we know she once used to be a part of
atlantica so why did she leave
did she get into a fight with king
triton or did she leave by herself
which brings us to our second ursula
plot hole why has no one tried to get
rid of her yet
literally everyone treats her as the
voldemort of the little mermaid they
even gasp when her name is mentioned
so why hasn't anyone tried to take her
down is it because she's too powerful
too scary or are they all just extremely
lazy
because we feel that that's right
if you've watched the little mermaid you
know there's plenty of ships that meet
their end at the bottom of the sea
ariel even hides her human treasure in
one of them and if you also remember the
ships are pretty well
wrecked so how exactly does ursula
conjure one up from the bottom
of the sea and have eric actually become
captain of it just seems a little
far-fetched honestly
we get it ariel was super fascinated
with her feet when she turned human
because well
that's what was gonna help her walk but
i mean if you one day turned from a
mermaid
to a human we think there would be more
than just your feet to find fascinating
yep we went there but are we lying
from the way the entire movie played out
it seemed like mermaids were a complete
secret to the humans
maybe we were wrong after ariel and eric
defeat ursula the two get married and
then sail away
but they don't get far before a crowd of
mermaids comes to the surface to bid
them farewell
so did the humans know mermaids existed
the entire time
or did they just decide to reveal
themselves because of ariel
we talked about how sebastian was able
to communicate with eric in the movie
which means that everyone
human and fish included speaks english
but is that really accurate
have you ever tried to speak underwater
nothing ever clearly comes out so how
was ariel
able to learn proper english under the
sea magic
nothing happened oh ariel
although she's a mermaid ariel is the
size of your average human
well apparently she doesn't weigh the
same as an average human though
after ursula turns ariel into a human
she starts to drown
naturally so in order to save her
sebastian and flounder hook onto her and
swim her up to the surface of the water
i don't know about you but we're pretty
sure a fish
would never be able to save us from
drowning
ariel's contract with ursula was
basically a ticking time bomb
she had to have true love's kiss in
three days or else she'd stay a mermaid
and belong to the sea witch forever
so um why didn't she just try a tad
harder to kiss eric
maybe she wanted to set the mood but not
everything is a fairy tale ariel
it definitely would have saved her a lot
of pining
remember when ursula and eric almost
happened what a wild time
eric literally decided to marry her the
same day he met her and everyone was
just like
okay this may be a movie about a talking
fish but that literally makes no sense
wouldn't grimm have questioned his
choices even a little bit
to finish this plot hole sequence off
there are just a few things that don't
add up in ariel's ocean life
the first being all the sun they get at
the bottom of the ocean
i mean they could literally tan
shouldn't the bottom of the ocean be
pitch black and finally they must have
some super special paper under the water
because whenever it pops up
it's not the soggy mess you'd expect it
to be call us disney trash but we still
love the little mermaid just as much as
we did before that's the beauty of
disney
plot holes and all have you noticed any
more fishy story lines in the film
which plot hole was the most shocking
don't forget to drop all your thoughts
in the comment section below
we hope you'll hit that subscribe button
and give this video a thumbs up and
we'll see you next time
you